on dit souvent que l'enfer est pavé de
bonnes intentions
et ça décrit plutôt bien ce qui s'est
passé dans la plaine inondable du lac
saint-pierre dans cet écosystème but
ultra sensible qui existent grâce aux
inondations saisonnières
on est intervenu pour sauvegarder
certaines espèces et aujourd'hui on
mesure les conséquences de ce geste
pourtant bien intentionnés
[Musique]
c'était un beau rêve
desmarest artificielle qui devait
favoriser la bernache au printemps et
servir l'agriculture en été mais ces
marais sont devenus une source de
pollution
il empoisonne lac saint-pierre et
polluent le saint laurent
ces aménagements étaient pourtant
l'oeuvre d'une des plus importantes
sociétés de conservation au canada nous
avons voulu comprendre comment les
acteurs de l'époque en sont arrivés à ce
résultat
quel regard porte-t-il trente ans plus
tard sur les façons de faire de la
conservation
[Musique]
dans ses temps libres cet agronome est
diplômé en biologie devient apiculteurs
c'est pour lui une autre façon dit-il
d'apprivoiser le vivant on les a
introduit deux à bernard fignon est un
des piliers de la conservation au québec
il dirige la société canards illimités
un organisme sans but lucratif qui
aménage des milieux humides pour la
sauvagine
en quarante ans de conservation
il a piloté l'aménagement d'une centaine
de milieux humides mais à renens sa
retraite
les marais de baie-du-febvre entre
québec et montréal reste une tache à son
dossier
c'est pour ce qu'il fallait faire c'est
sûr que le constat c'est parce qu'on
aurait pu faire à l'époque donc les
connaissances nous verrons qu'il faut
faire marche arrière
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
pour comprendre ce qui cloche avec ces
marais nous accompagnons bernard filion
à baie du febvre
[Musique]
devant nous une partie de la vaste
plaine inondable du lac saint pierre
ces terres ont toujours été inondé par
la crue printanière du saint laurent
mais plus maintenant une digue empêche
depuis trente ans ce va-et-vient du lac
saint pierre
donc on est ce qu'on est sûr la fameuse
dit ici oui on est sur la digue la
cellule numéro 2 donc on peut voir que
c'est très long elle les pentes douces
et que le ceinturent le territoire
complètement pour de façon à empêcher
une inondation
le printemps est d'accumuler de l'eau
[Musique]
une digue donc qui joue un double rôle
au printemps elle permet d'accumuler
l'eau de la fonte des neiges et de créer
une aire d'alimentation pour la
sauvagine en pleine migration
une fois les oiseaux reparti en mai on
pompent cette eau vers le lac
saint-pierre liberté ici les terres pour
y faire de l'agriculture
à l'époque ce projet fait l'unanimité
la halte migratoire de baie du febvre
reçoit même la sanction du conseil des
ministres de 1988 c'était l'exemple
parfait de fond d agriculture c'est
comme ça qu'il s'était présenté
c'est vraiment une façon et ça a duré
longtemps ce but lourds à savoir fournir
culture s'est passé puis c'est possible
à baie du febvre c'est un exemple été
cité or ce mariage parfait s'est fait au
détriment du lac saint pierre
[Musique]
le lac saint-pierre possède la plus
vaste plaine inondable en eau douce du
québec
on y retrouve 60% des milieux humides du
saint laurent
cette plaine est fréquenté par plusieurs
espèces d'oiseaux et de poissons dont la
perchaude qui vient d'y déposer ses yeux
au printemps
canards illimités et riches ces digues
en 1990 l'organisme bloqué si l'accès à
225 hectares de plaines inondables pour
plusieurs espèces de poissons
qu'à cela ne tienne le milieu applaudi
ces marais profiteront au bar moteur
mais surtout à la bernache une espèce
qu'on cherche à protéger
or rien de tout ça en est arrivé là
prennent inondable est reconnu comme un
habitat très riche
ce qu'on constate dans les cellules qu
on a à mon avis c'est très pauvre
non on arrive on sent on constate
qu'effectivement oui loin blanche et la
mêlée est en augmentation par cause des
dommages aux récoltes se taire on n'a
aucun avantage à maintenir sauf si c'est
pour le peutrec en restant de sa vie
puis quand les structures sont non
fonctionnel que la digue ce est perforé
c'est envahi de poissons qui sont
frappés donc faut sortir les poissons à
la tonne
mais il ya plus après des décennies on
se rend compte que ces marais ont des
impacts beaucoup plus sournois
nous sommes au début mai date où les
oiseaux migrateurs quittent le secteur
regardez bien cette photo aérienne
incroyable mais ce panache d'eau sale
provient des marais artificiel donc les
survole le territoire
je retrouvais je vois le dire quand est
construite puis je vois là où ce que les
tombes rejette l'eau vers la l'accent
est bien une brune une eau chargée de
sédiments donc de sol qui était mis en
suspension par les oies blanches qui
sont comme des bas tarifs qui brasse
tout ce solo et avec tout lille ce qui
vient avec les sédiments mêler tous les
nutriments agricole ils sont rejetés
vers l'axé blair
nous avons demandé à ce spécialiste de
nous décrire l'impact que cause le
drainage de ces marais artificiel peu de
personnes ont documenté la dégradation
du lac saint pierre comme philippe
brodeur lorsqu'on actionne les pompes en
mai on fait plus loki contenues dans les
endiguements qui est de très faible
qualité los d'une eau qui est chargé en
sédiments nutriments pesticides ces
zones sont rejetées vers le lac
saint-pierre pour compenser qu'il ya des
habitants et des frayeurs il ya de la
forme qui se retrouvent à l'extérieur
des digues
puis l'eau mauvaise qualité est racheté
par ses habitants la moitié des 79
espèces de poissons du lac saint-pierre
utilisent les herbiers de la plaine
inondable la perchaude souffrent tout
particulièrement du pompage de cette eau
turbide sa population est dans un état
critique
des études récentes ont montré que la
turbidité de l'eau du lac saint-pierre
entraîné plusieurs problématiques des
problématiques dirait des retards de
croissance au niveau des jeunes stade de
personnes qui aussi avait un impact sur
la croissance des herbiers sur merger au
lac saint pierre
les herbiers c'est comme une forêt
l'équivalent d'une forêt sous marine
c'est dans ces habitants alors que se
développent toute la nourriture des
poissons dans sa de la perche orne
les conclusions des spécialistes et des
études que nous avons consultés sont
unanimes les marais artificielle de
baie-du-febvre pollue lac saint-pierre
et détériorent son écosystème
est-ce qu'on accepte son est ce qu'on se
ferme les yeux l'aveu de la main
volontaire puis quand dieu non c'était
bien fait été conçue puces et bah moi je
dis non
[Musique]
la plaine inondable de baie-du-febvre
pourrait bien changer de visage au cours
des prochains mois canards illimités et
la fondation de la faune du québec
investiront 2 millions de dollars pour
remettre le site en état
cet automne on fait marche arrière on
démantèle la grande île côté ouest côté
nar de façon à donner de la liberté au
fleuve dont on rend son espace de
liberté pour qu'elles l'inondation
naturel reviennent comme c'était dans un
et 80
en tout on retire à 5 km de digues
le projet a reçu l'aval du ministère de
la faune et celui de l'environnement du
québec
[Musique]
mais revenir en arrière ne fait pas que
des heureux
jusqu'ici impossible pour canards
illimités de retirer ces digues une
entente légale liait l'organisme aux
agriculteurs qui cultivent ces terres
[Musique]
mais cette convention prend fin en 2020
soit partagée au point de vue
professionnel
oui j'ai hâte de voir ça mais l'impact
ça va avoir ces individus me préoccupe
aussi ceux qui vont perdre cette
facilité qu'on est là qu'on a créé à
l'époque je peux pas être indifférents
seulement
c'est sa grille culteurs perdront la
protection que leur offraient les digues
contre les crues du lac saint pierre
[Musique]
le yar'adua moitié le à moitié du
terrain à peu près de deux heures
christian lemire restera propriétaire de
ses terres et pourra continuer de les
cultiver
il devra abandonner les cultures les
plus rentables
[Musique]
le messe puis soyons pour plus de 1000
passes peau ben non on va l'essayer puis
si un cru les autres ou importante
avance un allié on va perdre la récolte
pendant la préparation de ce reportage
les agriculteurs touchés par le retrait
des digues ont déposé une action en
justice afin de forcer l'arrêt des
travaux
y a plus que chez nous le tout tout le
littoral de tout le monde cultive dans
la la zone inondable pays
ceci sera assis avec nous autres canards
l'on n'aura pu en discuter et trouver
des moyens une autre leur argument c'est
la sédimentation et on aurait pu la
première année qu'on entend parler de
tout
[Musique]
bernard filles on ignore pour l'instant
s'il y aura ou non retrait des digues
mais il ne blâme pas ses agriculteurs
il remet plutôt en question la décision
prise à l'époque d'ériger des digues en
pleine zone inondable une erreur commise
par tous les acteurs de la conservation
en les eaux permis avec les et de faire
la ligne culture dans un endroit où ce
qu'on n'aurait pas dû faire ça c'est ça
le problème
l'enjeu les lourds c'est une
incompréhension
la fragilité des stars y voir là à
l'époque
[Musique]
baie-du-febvre met en lumière la
difficulté de faire de l'agriculture et
même de la conservation dans un milieu
hautement sensible comme une plaine
inondable
il faut permettre la libre circulation
de nous la circulation du poisson donc
les va-et-vient d'inondations
d'exhortation c'est ce défi nommé
naturel kondoki qui doivent être
maintenus dans littoral du lac 5 à 7 à
la base la productivité de cet
écosystème
ces marais il faut aussi prendre
conscience des erreurs commises au nom
de la conservation
aujourd'hui on protège d'abord
l'ensemble d'un habitat avant de penser
à sauvegarder une seule espèce encore un
marais marécages
on conçoit pas ça pour une espèce on
conçoit un habitant qui lui vaut ac
accommoder va accueillir des poissons
les oiseaux
oui la sauvagerie des espèces un bac d
amphibiens
ses habitants sont beaucoup plus
résilient beaucoup plus robuste
[Musique]